we've been thinking
a lot about courage this week and about
compliance
and about
um
really at some level this this just
little excerpt from catch 22 which you
would remember it and i found in in our
book here
um
was prompted by our talking about how so
many of the renditions
of the
the resistors
the um
those those who do not comply those who
uh say no i'm not going along
the the life that is portrayed of them
tends to be one of
um
one of darkness
and um paucity and one of austerity
austerity and sort of you know the image
that comes to mind it's always it's sort
of like a grayscale
you know
liquid of unknown provenance dripping
from ducts onto you you can't ever quite
get warm or dry there are very few
comforts it's a dreary dark choice but
you know if you're that kind of person
then you go
and we wanted to talk
about
the other way to view this right and in
fact the reality so there's of course a
great deal of effort invested in
spooking people into imagining that if
they say what they see
then terrible things will befall them
and that you know that keeps a lot of
people in line
you don't want rats crawling over your
toes while you sleep do you
i don't no i don't think so um
but i mean that's the sort of thing that
that's that's the imagery right like
okay
you step out of line and pretty before
you know it that's the kind of life
you're going to be having right and
indeed you know uh
in the current environment i should
point out that when you say resistors
there is this hashtag resistance thing
that i don't want any partner i don't
even know that um well it's a you know
it's a throwback to the um the election
in fact the 2016 election but the idea
is it's a branded kind of resistance
rather than people who are actually
resisting the orthodoxy in fact it's
become a kind of orthodoxy but
nonetheless uh there is this interesting
phenomenon
where if you actually do
first principles thinking you call it
like you see it and you do so publicly
things do happen
right and not all of them are good to be
sure and we have um
lost uh quite a number of friends in uh
in recent times
over calling it like we see it
with respect to issues related to the
pandemic yes what else though the other
thing though what they don't manage to
convey is that this causes a kind of
upgrade in your social life because the
people who uh
you know publicly chastise you in such
circumstances are actually not high
quality they may seem like it under
normal circumstances but
when the chips are down they won't be
there and that's actually a very
important thing to know we learned this
at evergreen too right but let's just be
very clear and i know you know
the the viewers who are long time
viewers who are coming here because they
find something of value uh will not have
made this error um but i could hear what
you just said as suggesting that if you
get critiqued you know that person is no
no no is it doing you a solid and isn't
worth having a right no no a great
friend will critique you they will do it
carefully but there is uh you know
there's this public distancing thing
that uh is of a very different sort and
we saw this at evergreen and of course
the first time we learned this lesson
when this happened at evergreen
you know there were lots of people who
we had thought were our friends who
turned out not to be up to the challenge
but a great many people emerged and the
point was the trade was very positive
right the upgrade and the quality of
people that surrounded us was amazing
now what we would say at the time in
fact was that there were surprises on
boat in both directions and we've been
we've begun asking some of the some of
our new friends some of the people whom
we are coming into contact with okay
when you when you spoke up when you
became public on whatever topic it is
um that you are now persona non grata in
your former social circles did you find
you know what did you find out we try
not to lead the witness you know we try
not to tell people what it is that we
already think we know and what what
people
say over and over again is it it is a
reaffirmation of we ourselves found
which is that there are surprises in
both directions meaning that some of the
people who we thought um would be
um
loyal as friends even if they didn't
agree with the conclusions um
were not you know were cowardly word
disloyal
did not act as friends and some people
with whom we actually didn't know that
we had any affinity or affiliation at
all stood up and acted courageously and
boldly because they too could not bear
to observe
an injustice or
you know
you know authoritarianism flying under
the banner of anti-racism or science or
whatever it is right so uh i guess what
i would say is you know you could simply
count heads right and frankly i don't
know what the
net is our social circle grew a lot
after uh evergreen that's not
necessarily what's taken place
in modern times but the point is if you
do so waiting for quality then what you
find is that actually you discover
incredibly um
interesting dynamic
people who are excellent at careful
thought right and so anyway there is
this kind of upgrade phenomenon that is
not famous people do not know that you
know that this is part of the equation
and so there is a question we do hear
from people and i think this is
justified uh you know okay but but you
guys us we're findable and indeed so
many people reach out to us that we
don't we we aren't able to respond to
most people who do and so i'm sure you
know we miss lots of people who are
amazing who reach out to us who we just
never follow through with because
because we don't have too many yeah um
we don't have the time for it um we
don't have that you know time is finite
um but for tho for those of you who
don't have a way like how how do people
find one another and i guess that's you
know what we're trying to say is being
courageous is
not inherently going to
bring you a life in which rats are
running over your toes in your sleep
but how is it that people find the
community of other people like them who
are
who are not seeing the world the way
they're being told to see it
well
i think
what what my impression after evergreen
was i wish you know
if there were to be you know a minute of
supernatural stuff right and you could
pick what the supernatural thing was the
ability to know
who actually had the characteristics
that would
render them strong in adverse
circumstances and who
seemed like they might be that person
but was destined to disappoint this is
the most important piece of information
you could have right you do not want to
discover once you're in the foxhole that
the person who talked a good game
actually has no courage and will sell
you out right you don't want that you
want to know ahead of time who really
has the depth of character so that what
you encounter on the surface
is actually indicative of what's below
and you don't know that until a severe
challenge and so
in essence there is no substitute
for the high pressure test of the system
so i i guess my point is i believe that
anybody who stands up will discover this
they will find out that many around them
who they think are you know and who are
more than decent under normal
circumstances will fail the test under
uh dire circumstances well so two things
i hope i remember both of them here um
we have found
you know when we are anonymous in the
world as we're moving about and
increasingly that's not necessarily the
case and frankly i i
mourn the loss of anonymity because uh
for me as an animal behaviorist a lot of
what i learn about people is by going
out into the world and not just
observing but interacting with them as
just you know a human being who doesn't
already have stated opinions in the
world
um and you know i do we we get
recognized and approached and it's it's
lovely we've yet to be approached by
anyone for with whom it wasn't lovely
but i always feel a sort of sense of
like oh i you know that means that i
can't do that i can't be learning in the
way that i would be learning from here
because i don't know to what degree this
is um
this is a show
right
um
but when we have both you and i do this
in somewhat different ways and largely
in
overlapping but somewhat non-overlapping
like retail venues
ask people just show any little
indicator of not being totally on board
with whatever the dominant paradigm is
right now and this you know last in
summer of 2020 here in portland it was
largely about the responses to
uh the protesters that became rioters
every night and it was about the you
know shutting down police and it was uh
it was about black lives matter and
increasingly it's about um you know
lockdowns and outdoor masks and and
vaccine mandates and it is amazing how
many people seem not only willing but
eager to take the smallest hint that
maybe you were not an automaton that
maybe you haven't swallowed the dominant
thing hook line and sinker and will then
just talk we'll talk and you know and
sometimes a little bit but sometimes it
seems like they're going for hours about
what it is they're actually seeing what
they think it means and how
how bad
the public policy and the uniform public
response seems to be
yeah actually um
i
i'm sure i'm sure that this has been
understood by those who have analyzed
authoritarianism but one of the
hallmarks has to be when you you know
coerce a population into compliance
the pressure on individuals
is immense and
the
desire for those individuals to find
somebody that they can actually be safe
in talking about what they don't like
about it in other words there's a danger
in confessing yeah actually i'm not on
board with this
right even if i'm complying it's not
because i think this is a good idea
but people cannot people will not in
general be public about this because the
hazard of saying the wrong thing to the
wrong person is too great um so if you
you know put out a little bit of bat
signal yes i do have a cat who's
crawling in my lap here if you put out a
little bit of a bat signal
right and i mean in fact this is this is
where we are i would say
on masks right
the mask thing has clearly become about
compliance and i will say for the
thousandth time
we were
extremely early on the idea of masks and
um the failure of the evidence it seemed
obvious it seemed we were compelled
that it seemed obvious and that the u.s
surgeon general know who and you know
fouchy and everyone else is like don't
wear masks that would be foolish and
then they came out with like no actually
that was to preserve the ppe for the
healthcare workers
that that seemed obvious to us i think i
think we were wrong
right i think we i think we were wrong i
think there is a small amount of good
it's not enough to justify mandates it
requires
a certain kinds of masks b it requires
that they be worn in very particular
ways and the point is it's just not
justified but it's been a marvelous
policy from the point of view of
discovering who will they agree to this
right who will go along with uh with
mandates that make no sense and it's
been just you know really picture
perfect with respect to taking the
message
be frightened and transporting it
everywhere it rides around with every
citizen who has to put on a mask or walk
around with it we get these reminders
constantly you know there's a pandemic
these people are a danger to you right
and now the thing is the unmasked the
unvaccinated the uns
are dirty and dangerous yeah and perhaps
evil
right now you and i
um are compliant mask-wise we don't fail
we live in a state and a a city a state
and a coast um that is largely masked
right so we put them on we are not
flaunting inside inside retail
establishments except when we're eating
well no no hold on we are compliant with
the requirement to wear a mask the harm
while
there is small enough that we are not
going to uh
uh ignore the rule
however
there is no rule that says you have to
play along with the idea that this makes
sense right and so
when one sits down at the table and
takes off their mask in a restaurant as
if they're you know as if this is like
smoke that if you get below it you can
you can breathe again
um you know one is
perfectly free to evidence yes i'm
complying but i think this is nonsense
um well i think it's actually it's an oh
sorry um it was it's i was in a booth in
a restaurant in austin actually with
uh with a friend and he said wow this is
like the one square mile in all of texas
where masks are required and if he
actually had not come with one and i was
able i was like oh god i know i have so
many here take one of mine um and we sat
down and because we're in a booth he
said oh it's it's not about the smoke
it's actually there's the invisible
force field that comes across the booth
as long as everyone else stays outside
of our force field we have no chance of
spreading the thing that we don't have
right the thing that you don't have yeah
right and you know you the the paradoxes
are so many you know when you have
you know the the waiter comes over
wearing a mask right and you're sitting
there not masked and actually my sense
is to the extent that this does any good
at all
we're more or less morally obligated to
put them on at that moment to protect
this person right it is only because i
don't think this is a very effective
remedy that i don't think this is a
glaring error because it's you know i
mean and that's what i was doing until i
started to see all of this um
all of this work suggesting that they're
not actually particularly effective yeah
but anyway yes um
a little bat signal that suggests uh i
don't think this policy is all that well
thought out is liable to put you in
contact with others who have those
doubts and are likely feeling very
isolated about them themselves yeah and
really there's a
there's a smugness that some people are
willing and eager to
to convey
uh and then
it's not there's everyone else
but that is one of the ways that is one
of the dichotomies that i am seeing now
there's the smug
who
largely you know are actually
functionally enumerate i think and um
and get your nose out of my water um she
is not talking to me for those of you
listening to the podcast he's talking to
the cat
um
and
you know who say things like follow the
science but don't actually you know
wouldn't recognize a hypothesis if it
smacked him in the nose
and then there's sort of everyone else
and yes there are degrees to which um
the everyone else have conclusions that
they're certain of or not certain of or
have investigated them as much as
possible for reverse principles
but there is a degree of uncertainty
the you know the smug are inherently
certain and if you're certain right now
that the thing that got handed you by
the cdc or msnbc or anyone is simply
true on account if it got handed to you
then you're not doing your thinking for
yourself and frankly your smugness is it
should evaporate right away because it's
based on nothing good
[Music]
you